now when people know I'm coming trust me
they do their best to stay in line so
I'm going undercover
time to raise some hell
[Music]
oh walking in broadwalk 11 feels like
two different restaurants the bar is
state of the art
while the restaurant is in a state of
despair and complete neglect oh that's
worthy I guess the karaoke happens I
know you guys know what you want I think
so yeah but a table will take the
sliders to go with that keg in the
corner we're ordering some Gastropub
Staples
The Deco this trap Ryan how bad is that
something's in the lab
whoever runs this place they lost
enthusiasm about the place a long time
ago it feels that way doesn't it
you still need meatballs got it
foreign
got your beef sliders order of meatballs
and Keith sweatshirt oh thanks
it's sweet I found out how fast this
food's coming out it's just processed it
yeah yeah it's defrosted yeah
it smells like dog food the meat and
these slices smell like they've gone bad
it's sour it's it's turned are you
serious the meatballs smell just like
the burger is that what that smell is oh
my God it smells like the carpet all
right it is disgusting I'm gonna take
your word for that one
and the meat is great
oh my God
Dead on Arrival we killed the bastard
Burger yeah he is the biggest bastard in
Lay preparing a burger like that my God
yeah
um ladies and gentlemen
please can I ask you put your knife and
forks down
first of all
that was one of the worst meals I've
ever had I'm in shock
honestly you guys should be ashamed
[Music]
because that was embarrassing
dirty menus thrown down
then the food arrives
I've never seen food hit the table so
quick in all my [__] life
I sense has been microwaved and then
literally just thrown down cat your head
chef right just out of Interest how long
ago those meatballs cooked like four
days ago
what is this just to dive bar we thought
we had pretty decent food we were trying
our best home lots of words and you're
saying the food is good saying the food
is good it's not great but it's the best
that we can do that was a [__]
embarrassment everybody else stop eating
broadwalk 11 is closed meet me outside
can't even stand up straight
right hit me so I'm going undercover
[Music]
Grandpa Jim ready for lunch
Annette
how are you gorgeous I see you Brian and
Walter best behavior please
belt's on
now how does this thing start oh oh geez
[__] that's a long time since basketball
driving test okay
let's go
thank God there's no dress code
unfortunately there doesn't appear to be
a dress code for the restaurant's
interior either
the assortment of colors and hair on the
chairs is ridiculous it's like a rainbow
of mess
and how in the [__] do you get through
these menus on one side of the menu
you've got potential dishes and the
other side you've got ads I mean how
tacky is that upholstery oh my God we've
got tail here the menu is 22 pages long
I may die before I get to the end of it
as before [__] eating
[Music]
few minutes
maybe some beef tamales beef tamales
we're ordering some classic Mexican
dishes I'm gonna get the chicken mole
the shrimp tacos at a place like Los
Toros should have mastered can I get the
color again
yeah
hey Dad yeah huh
at least that's what we're thinking
95 where 15.
I think they've spotted it as me yeah
Chef Ramsay it's gonna be him I know
it's gonna be him
tamales first so one for each okay
let me get more napkins okay it does not
scream like fresh tomato
yeah
you want to set it in a nice corn husk
yeah yeah exactly kind of make it
somewhat look homemade honey will you
stop eating that [__] thing
I need you tonight
it's my birthday you promised me see
this one right here
goes out with this morning I'm gonna go
look for myself right now
so guys two orders of shrimp tacos
you guys that's me
oh yeah you can tell it's old yeah
how's that chicken Wally it's really bad
the aftertaste is like I mean it's just
important
ladies watching us now so I have to be
careful
they keep on the staring over
I'm going out of the car to change my
colostomy bag because it's coming
through quicker than I expected
[Music]
is holding on for dear life so my team
told the restaurant that they were
trying out for a traditional renovation
show whilst they were being interviewed
we installed hidden cameras throughout
the restaurant and have been secretly
recording Simone's footage ever since we
left and even with the best disguise in
this tiny little restaurant I'll stick
out like a sore thumb
do you have any idea how long it took me
to grow this so I've decided for your
undercover to hide in plain sights
cameraman buddy ready for action
[Music]
hiding behind this camera I feel
invisible
the decor is Dreadful this place is run
down it clearly hasn't seen love in
years who wants to sit down on that
though hot sauce
do you know if we're going to have
oxtails at all today no 86 oxtails
there's no more grits all we have is
country potatoes
well I don't know we ran out [__] I'm
just
clearly no love lost on the food either
why are you guys holding on to the
dishes so much
you're all going okay you were supposed
to bring me a mobile thing forgot all
the boxes oh my God I'm waiting on the
dish man oh you forgot about me I'm
gonna forget about your ass right now I
don't even want that man I said
smothered pork chops bruh man you didn't
say no smother you don't say that on
your receipt
management
sitting down in the restaurant would
blow my cover so Ernie and I have taken
our food to go
um visually it looks as bad in here as
it is on the plates I mean it's just
slopped yeah again so that's a fried
chicken with greens I mean it just looks
old it's not a lot of flavor there's no
flavor there whatsoever and there's
certainly not seasoned on the breading
we'll have those greens they need a lot
more seasoning do you know every
customer throwing salt yeah pepper
pepper everyone peppered it twice
that's Bland so the fried chicken the
greens a big No-No right
fried catfish sandwich that tartar sauce
that stinks
oh
the smell there
no
meatloaf oh that's me looks like
something that's sort of slipped out my
granddad's underpants look at that that
gravy there whatever that is on there
that's just cream
don't do it oh oh my God that is
terrible
get back in there yeah yeah all right
let's go
[Music]
um ladies and gentlemen
can I just ask you to stop eating knife
and forks down turn off the stove oh
that's Gordon Ramsay
oh my god
oh you're the mean Chef
could I just have silencer for 30
seconds please stop eating Madam Carrie
I've been here for the last 90 minutes I
understand while the rest is struggling
madeira's is officially close can you
all follow me please I ain't gonna do
too well with him oh my Lord